we'll start with the taliban invaded
afghanistan
and biden withdrew the troops
and the airport was uh overrun
and uh there's incredible video and
we'll we'll show it in a few minutes
there's incredible video of folks
clinging to the aircraft and clinging to
the landing gear literally you know last
helicopter out of hanoi
it has that it's reminiscent of that so
are people escaping
this is sorry afghani refugees hanging
on to our planes trying to get out of
there because uh the taliban overran
the so basically
the taliban was in charge of security at
the airport essentially uh the perimeter
the the entire place was overrun by
taliban
and we had uh americans trying to get
out of there and you know interpreters
and folks that were friendly to us
during the last 20 years
of that skirmish and it was a total
bleep show
and so we actually had to send troops
back
into afghanistan to go to that airport
and try to extract
americans and folks that were considered
friendly to us although
we're of course not successful in
getting everyone out
so we so we got some people out and did
you say now we're taking our troops out
like is that is it done i mean if the
idea here so so we're officially leaving
afghanistan is that there were some
rumblings about that sort of at the end
of july i mean i'm you know it's the
longest war in american history i'm
completely fine with ending that war
yeah so what happened was and in terms
of the narrative is i think
most
most all democrats and many republicans
say
let's get out of afghanistan why do we
need to keep this going now if you
listen to guys like ben shapiro
they'll say we had 2500 troops there
and nobody had died in a year and a half
so is that really an endless war
and he makes a good point like we have
troops stationed in you know japan and
germany we we have troops
around the world they're not involved
with an endless war they're just there
you know
and so to kind of paint it
as you know not another american killed
or these sons and daughters are going
over there and never coming back it's
not totally accurate because
in the last you know in the last
uh seven years
they lost you know 10 people
and you know we always have to say it's
all it's always a tragedy anyone lost
you know blah blah blah
understood but
if you have no
fatalities in the last year and a half
is that an endless war right so what's
what's the main media narrative on this
is it that it was somehow a failure of
the biden administration that we lost
this airfield and had to leave and i
mean i got to see the video here
obviously but like
is that what the narrative is or is the
narrative like oh biden is doing what
trump never did or something like that
well the media is has a couple of uh
stratus to it so the first is biden is
pulling everyone out good for him
second one was it turned into such a
cluster f that even cnn couldn't ignore
it you know what i mean you can't ignore
i should run the video for you
you can't ignore video of people
clinging to the landing gear of a c-130
aircraft yeah wait real quick though
before we throw to the video so that's
interesting though was did they
basically try to ignore it at first the
mainstream media because it was going to
make the administration look bad like
that like it was going around twitter
and the rest of it and then eventually
they just couldn't ignore it anymore
no they didn't do what they normally do
which is
ignore it for as long as they can
because it happened
so quickly and literally overnight and
there was so much dramatic footage
coming from that region
that even cnn couldn't ignore it they
all had to jump into it they then kind
of corrected their narrative
and i'll i'll explain that momentarily
but i think first we should take a look
at the video of the the kabul uh airport
and the tarmac and people trying to flee
so we'll we'll show that
taliban fighters took control of the
capital less than 20 years after u.s
forces overthrew their government
afghanistan's president fled the country
and much of the population is in hiding
afraid of what's next with scenes like
this and unable to get on a flight we
decided to stay
taliban fighters soon declared an end to
the war from the comfort of the
presidential palace just hours after
strolling into kabul just 11 days after
launching an offensive overwhelming u.s
trained afghan forces in cities across
afghanistan
[Applause]
[Music]
there's dramatic footage of people
falling off as it climbs to altitude
obviously to their death
so it was so dramatic that cnn couldn't
ignore it and uh everyone then
agreed that you know this was a total
show
and and that that it was biden's
he botched it he bought am i understand
this correctly so the taliban is now
like basically officially in charge of
afghanistan again yes as if we just
erased 20 years
yes except for
now
taliban is sort of the new government
there we're now dealing with the taliban
as if we're dealing with france and the
leaders of you know macron or something
like that so
and now we hope that isis has re-emerged
as well
and so now we're trying to work with the
taliban to keep
isis at bay but there's there's much
more to catch you up on so
okay good start so so uh a country fell
basically and it sounds like another war
is brewing like it pauses on a war with
a new war on the way
it essentially fell overnight if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell